CALGARY WANTED FROM YOUE
YOUR HEAD ON A
SWIVEL.
DARYRY
PUCK SAKE AND
HAS TO PUT THE
SOMEBODY ON SOMEBODY
WAY AND NOAH
ANDERSSON AND
GAUDREAU SETTLES
SAYS THAT MAYBE HE
PUNCHED HIM
IN THAT AREA.
IT COORDINATION
THERE AND BOY, THAT THE
ICE.
THE HAWKS HAVE HADAN SO
HOPEFULLY HE IS OKAY.
HERETHE
SLOT RIGHT NOW.
AND LINDHOLM AND
BELL TAKE IS THERE
HIS WAY OFF OF THE
ICE.
>> RADDYSH GOT BEAT
TO THE MIDWAY POINT
REGULA.
INTERCEPTED AND
DEBRINCAT  ONE.
ALEX REGULA FIRST
SCORE AS AAND
AROUND.
PREGAME LIVE RIGHTK
KING SAID ABOUT THE LETT
TOO FAR OUT
THE
CIRCLE.
AND BACKLUND HASDROPPED
DO THIS
EXTRA ATTACKER AND
MATTHEW TKACHUK TIED
UP AND DOWN TO THEREAU
EMPTY NET AND HE HE
INJURED THE LEAGUE
ROLLING AND SAN JOSE.
>> LOOKS LIKE THE
THTH